hey guys I'm Dan I'm Jeff it's the
middle of the wait so let's get you
through it with some gaming news our
watch is coming to Sydney reminding me
of that one time Dan was really
jet-lagged and said wouldn't it be cool
if our watch had an Australian character
why would you tell them that that's
right overwatch is coming to Sydney with
the return of Summer Games 2017 with a
bunch of changes and a new Lucille Ball
Arena Summer Games 2017 will run from
August 8 to 29 during which time you'll
be able to snag new and old event skins
and play over watch's version of soccer
Lucille Ball last year's legendary skins
including America are returning at the
discounted price of 1000 credits with
the 2017 legendary skins priced at 3000
credits during a developer update game
director Jeff Kaplan mentioned the bloke
you stay away from in every pub junk rat
will be getting a new skin as well as
HeLa mercy the limited time game-mode a
Lucille Ball now has two maps the
aforementioned Sydney arena and 2016
spree at stadiums there have also been
some changes to the mode with alou
series ability to boot enemies being
removed and the inclusion of a
competitive mode so you can place and
rank summer games 2017 is available for
free on ps4 Xbox one and PC if
competitive multiplayer isn't really
your speed this next one's for you the
delightful stardew valley it's getting
multiplayer later this year developer
chocolate fish has been hard at work
since the farming adventure games
released last year they announced today
that the long-awaited co-op mode that
will allow you to farm with three of
your friends will launch early in 2018
when starting out you can opt to have up
to three cabins built on your farm each
for one of your but those players can do
anything the main player can from
toiling in the fields to marrying an NPC
chuckle fish have received lots of
requests for player on player matrimony
too so they're looking to implement that
at some point each player will have a
separate inventory that becomes a chest
in their cabin when they're offline so
you don't have to worry about your
friends using all of your seeds while
you're afk the studio is planning a beta
version of the multiplayer mode on PC
for the end of 2017 with console
versions to be updated at an unspecified
time in 2018 the Nintendo switch version
which will launch later this year will
be the first console version to receive
the update let us know in the comments
if you're interested in some co-op
farming action
my game of the year so far is persona 5
so call me please that APUs tourney game
for 3df has just been announced the game
is called for Sona q2 and will serve as
a follow-up to 2014's persona q shadow
of the labyrinth
the Japanese teaser website doesn't have
a lot of information about the game but
it does feature the phantom thieves logo
so it's likely we'll see characters
returning from persona 5 fingers crossed
for Beth girl Makoto also boy crush to
escape persona q what's a crossover of
persona 3 and persona 4 and played like
a challenging first-person dungeon
crawler Atlas also recently announced to
dancing spin-off games for persona 3 and
persona 5 respectively a persona 5 anime
double air in 2018 and a lovely Joker
figure that Jessica is probably going to
drop about 60 bucks on that's everything
we have for you today enjoy the rest of
your day good job
I'm gonna throw you okay cuz I'm not I'm
going off script boy I'm going off
script never a good idea okay